you know guys fortnight has really
become a phenomena and a lot of you out
there love the game others not so much
like me but you know what I really hate
about fortnight is when some
disrespectful dude kills you and busts
out the worm or dabs on you I mean is a
dad even a dance that doesn't make any
sense and what is this what is that what
is the name for that why are we doing
this list this game isn't even an eSport
yet in fact can we just do another like
csgo top-10 or something I did did you
just bring this here the top 10 most
annoying for night dances slashing those
[Music]
we're starting off our list with the
throwback to the famous Carlton dance
[Applause]
sad
this dance has made an appearance in
countless video games and fortnight is
no exception and while at first you may
get hit with a rush of nostalgia it's
not unusual for one to be tilted by this
over-the-top dance move from Bel Air's
nerdiest son you see a player ahead of
you no skin no cover standing still
found ourselves a bogey he's a default
here which means that if that player
turns on you he'll likely bust out the
ninth entry on our list the bass dancing
fortnight has its roots in the NBC show
Scrubs what could hurt more than being
bested by a frugal gamer who refuses to
shell out VIII bucks for a slick dance
[Music]
sometimes for night is exciting and the
eighth most annoying dance on our list
is the perfect way to show your
appreciation for your own skills
[Music]
[Applause]
the aptly named jubilation gives you a
chance to rub your happiness right in
your opponent's face
whether it's a victory Royale Elaine
coming home from holidays or beating the
Texas Rangers this dance shows your
victim just how happy you are to have
bested them
[Music]
vii dance on our list is the most
obvious choice for those truly stylish
plays dropping that sweet
robotic pop after downing an enemy team
certainly has a classy feel to it
and with all that mechanical proficiency
on display sometimes you just need to
execute dance sequence you may not be
able to call our six and treat dance but
it makes supper and pure rage inducing
BM
this email lets you show your enemies
that you know just how much they hated
getting outplayed by you
[Music]
if it's one thing for eight has plenty
of its sodium chloride and no one is
stopping you from spreading a little
more
[Music]
if you're getting annihilated by a
four-man squad you know they're best
mates when they all drop the number-5
dance just just perfect view to watch
that whole thing round just chilling of
the tree just kind of like popularized
by Marlin Webb and his gang of
outlandish joggers the best made stance
brings the energy to your best forename
moments
fortnight has proven that its popularity
can breathe life back into any meat
flopping its way to number four is the
funkiest dance on our list when you
really need to rub it in dropping this
classic 80s breakdancing move on your
opponents is sure to get in their heads
oh well they're doing the worm on me
both of button and they put a campfire
here guys are Dex trying to pull this
move out at your friend's birthday party
might not be a smooth move but after the
victory Royale
nothing could be smoother Seamus someone
needed it there's this boy knock down
his voice now do you ever
oh Jesus let's do some celebration we
deserved after that basic basic basic oh
yeah Oh click that at the third place
spot on our list belongs to the
mesmerizing arm-flailing floss this
dance has become a sensation after
appearing on SNL and took the fortnight
community by storm with its surge of
popularity there's no shortage of
players flossing after an impressive
kill it's simple its effective and it's
everywhere our runner-up dance is the
dab
[Music]
okay maybe it's dance status is a bit
questionable but it's social
pervasiveness certainly isn't
I just shouted
[Music]
if you're looking for the simplest move
to send your enemies straight to tilts
Ville then this needs to be your go-to
move going down sergeant every part of
the dance that takes our number one spot
screams annoying
[Music]
from the music to the absurdity of the
moves it's impossible to stay composed
after losing a duel and seeing this
[Music]
this blood-boiling taunt is easily the
most annoying dancing fortnight
[Music]
oh yeah it also may be the most
recognizable fortnight dance IRL even
before making an appearance in the 2018
World Cup finals that's our list for
this week guys I don't worry about Colin
his sodium levels are a little bit
elevated but I'm sure he'll be back to
normal for next week's episode it's not
a dance Josh it's not dancing thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]